I used to get so many questions from
other students and you know people were
from all over the world and I was like
what's Saudi Arabia like you and you
could just tell them anything and they'
believe
it you could just make stuff up you be
like oh like you know my camel riding my
camel to school through the desert and
this and they're just like I would
believe that right now I feel go like
this you go like this I'm going to pour
the sand out and you make a
[Music]
wish and welcome to the wel show on
YouTube where today we finally get to
confront and Destroy zubie with facts
and
logic so it's time to be destroyed sir
no welcome to JK welcome
zie happy to have you um we want to so
we like to um first kick off this series
of videos we're going to have with you
by getting to know you a little bit sure
so uh who are you what are you all about
um maybe people here don't know yeah
sure so my name is zubie I'm an
independent rapper from the UK I'm also
an author of two books can you turn up
the UK accd a little bit more then
that's not
believable is do it bot bot um yeah I'm
a public speaker I also run a podcast
called real talk with zubie I've had
that going for five years interviewed
some very big guests including Elon Musk
Alex hosi um gosh a lot of people Mar
yes bartco episode not dropped yet not
dropped just
yet billionaire thousand hey man getting
get in the whole Spectrum yeah a lot lot
of big guests on there um I also do
public speaking in many different
countries I was born in England grew up
in Saudi Arabia family background from
Nigeria and I've been nomadic for the
past two and a half years so I say I
live in Dubai but I'm kind of all over
the place went to 14 different countries
just last year so you don't have any
pets huh no
pets to like I have six birds that was a
top question no pets um but yeah man uh
a lot of people know me for different
reasons um but I just try to put out
positivity into the world Inspire and
motivate people through my words and
actions and it's been going well thank
God I was pleasantly surprised when um I
saw your name on the call sheet because
sometimes Bart just gets people randomly
but I've been following you on Twitter
for quite some time oh and so I'm I'm
basically a fan so I was like really
like shocked when bark got you and I was
like what the [__] how do you even know
zubie and then barart was like he dm' me
and I'm like what and then so my
question is how do you know this guy um
o o o OG Fitness OG Fitness YouTube man
see Fitness connects people knew Fitness
Guru but you so you didn't think he was
a a comedian you knew him as a fit this
guy I knew him as a power he's like
that's news to me what do you mean he I
knew him as a powerlifter um but kind of
funny powerlifter maybe though he's a
funny man cuz Bart like dances by the
pool like
this yeah I mean when did you start when
did you start the barbell Brigade
Channel
2013 before it was Barber it was just
Fitness it was like I don't know 2009 or
something yeah yeah I want to say it was
more more than 10 years ago yeah so I
was just you know independent rapper in
the UK doing my thing and watching
YouTube and came came across some I
don't I don't know what video it was but
I've known who you are for a long time
forgettable video but you know who he
is you said uh a lot of people know you
for a lot of different things like
what's like your favorite thing that
people know you for and what's your like
least favorite breaking the British
women's deadlift record that one's kind
of fun all right so in in 2019 I
identified as a woman and I broke the
British women's deadlift record
congratulations it went it went very
viral and millions of people discovered
me from that um now surely you had to
pre for months and months and months and
months Fe technically I'd prepped for
over a decade yeah but on the day I just
kind of walked up to the bar and that's
a big accomplishment though that's huge
man that's huge congrats on that thank
you man thank you that's big than you
wow I didn't realize thank you takes a
special women to do such a thing yeah
Power yeah with the penis what the what
is the deadlifting record oh gosh so man
I remember that day so I think when I
checked it it was 210 kilos at the time
and that's an American American ma don't
no man that's actually pretty strong 210
kilos is that's like 400 maybe 470 480
oh wow something like that a lot so um
yeah I mean my my my PB was 275 which is
606 lb and so the video that went viral
was like 230 it was like it was like
5115 something like that okay so um yeah
that that was 5 years ago now and that
put me on a lot of people's radar the
strongest woman in Britain has that
record held strong is it still your I
haven't checked I mean we could Google
search British women's deadlift record
and um did you ever did you ever
identify back to man oh yeah I've been a
man ever since I've been a man ever
since I just um you look we live in
modern times you had a calling and um I
try to be as Progressive as possible so
as uh yeah I do what suits me at the
time they took it from you depending on
which bathroom I need they took it from
you oh yeah was it Richard Stevens
somebody named love lace love oh it's
been taken but but my my PB is still
significant higher than that so we're
going to edit that out cuz it was
correct false information it was correct
it was correct at the time I knew you
going to give us some misinformation
so what what made you feel like you had
to like prove a point with that video
was it like the world you f like the
world was like what the [__] going on
everything's upside down dude we've been
living in clown world for at least the
past decade and um I'd seen this
especially coming up from around 2015 or
so and I remember having conversations
with people saying hey like if these are
the rules you're going to just start
getting men saying that their women and
entering female sports and breaking
their records and stuff and then people
thought that I was being overly alarmist
or that it wasn't going to happen and
then um here we
are whether it's swimming weightlifting
Athletics MMA you we we've seen this
goofiness and all so obviously it's
absurd and I was just like oh okay um
what's the British women's deadlift
record in my weight class oh that's what
it is and I can do way more than that so
I just posted the video when I did it I
had 18,000 followers on Twitter at the
time and um I didn't think it was going
to be some big viral moment or some
career defining thing I just was like
lol you know this is kind of funny and
it just went crazy it hit a million
views in under 24 hours it got it put
geez it because you have to remember at
this time I was just an independent
rapper in the UK just doing my thing
whatever I didn't have a big audience in
the US or anything like that and that
just catapulted me into a whole
different realm um the US e set [__] up
oh dude it it went crazy it went cuz it
went viral globally so it was on it went
viral in the Fitness World in the
political world in the social commentary
world and the com just all these
different spheres I remember when the
when the Tweet was going viral and there
were just all these comments in comment
started coming in in different languages
this Mak sh there and there and there
all the women were praising him it went
it went crazy man it went crazy that
sounds like you were an inspiration for
all women and that's globally they
needed that yeah man got to smash that
glass ceiling and um also whoever hit it
before I don't think they went viral
while doing it so like there's something
to be said about I know something to be
said about that yeah man it it was a
funny moment that's how Joe Rogan
discovered me um I ended up I mean I
came out to the US I was there here like
September to September to November 2019
did just a that was my first time coming
to La that's when Joe Rogan was still
out here so I did his show I did the
Ruben report is when the daily wire were
out here so I did like Ben of hero show
and all these I just it just started
this these dominoes and and then you
fell off all the way here that's brutal
this is where people come to Die the
last Domino well I I would say we we we
we were the first to discover Matt Kim
so but that's cuz he's Asian who do you
think is more Clowny you think America's
more Clowny or UK's more us really us
easily you guys are cooler huh like
about all this woke stuff like you guys
created
yeah you guys are exporting It All
Around The World God damn it I know but
it wasn't supposed to be it wasn't
supposed to be like that we do feel
accountable kind of you know if I was a
better bully in high school maybe
something would happen you know what it
felt like it felt like I was marching
with my friends and we're like yeah
we're going to work for like rots and
then they started saying crazy [__] and
I'm like man I don't I don't know about
that that's little crazy no it's too
late it's too late it's too late like
what like I just wanted like equality
like this is good good and then they
just went no quality is not good enough
man they want equity and I'm like that's
I don't understand yeah I think Canada
might be even ahead of you guys though
Canada seems Canada's taking that ball
and they're they're just running into
what makes you cringe the most about our
culture American culture yeah wow
American culture that's even a strange
term because there's so many different
subsections of American culture this is
we all like Hamburg well I don't know
about that um goofiest thing wait phrase
that question one more time well when
when when you're in America what's the
silliest [__] you see that we just seem
to accept or whatever the
silliest um do you know what this isn't
answering the question directly but what
always strikes me in the US is
everything in look in the UK everything
operates in this window in most country
in some countries things operate in this
window and some it's this window us is
just on on on everything every type of
human being that you can imagine exists
in the this country there are human
beings that exist here that like love
guns hate guns some countries no guns
everything on on whatever it is social
cultural uh political there's just
there's just everything yeah there's
just everything so there's certain types
of people who you come across here and
I'm just like this type of person just
does not exist in any in America they do
and they have a community and they have
a group land of opportunities yeah it's
crazy we made fun of furries on this
show and we had actual furry lovers in
the comments being like this is [__]
up can't believe you guys make fun of
us yeah this is probably the only
country where I'm you could probably
become a millionaire by being a furry
like that's true if your feet are
properly proportioned you can you can
fly very high you can sink very low you
can yeah you can do whatever you want
crazy you're kind of making me it's a
good and bad thing yes it is it is but
that's why the freedom here is awesome
and that's why people fight for it cuz
you could literally do whatever the [__]
you want and be successful at whatever
you want yeah the volatility compared to
the freedom in the UK where they can
literally do whatever the [__] they want
and financially they don't have to pay a
bunch of [__] like we do doesn't UK got
doesn't UK got crazy taxes UK has crazy
taxes it has crazy taxes but like if I
want to do crypto things over there or
perhaps I want to gamble over there
gotta I don't get tax up and out the
[__] yeah actually there's a there's
a ranking of economic freedom scales and
um UK ranks higher than the US in
economic freedom but how do they Define
it and I believe it now because my my
neighbor he's the top earning poker
player in the whole world online or
whatever he's made so much money on
online and he has to leave here to go
play because he doesn't want to get
taxed out the [__] it's a balance
between how easy it is to open up a
business taxes all these other things
but what I know of the UK just from
Hannah is that they don't collect on
certain like thresholds like the way
that they Penny pinch here on every
every person so like if you're making
under a certain point like I don't know
like 20,000 or whatever just throwing
that number out there they don't even
care but there's some [__] right so
like you want to buy a car it's a lot
more yeah right where in like the like
Denmark like Sweden like Singapore you
got to pay like 2x pay 2x basically yeah
UK UK doesn't fit into that category you
get like a car for like a th000 bucks
there used used I was in Sweden and my
buddy was like or Denmark and my buddy's
like you got to buy the car I mean if
you go to like Denmark or Sweden then I
mean the top tax rates are above 50% so
I think the top marginal tax I'm I won't
get the countries right it's Denmark and
Sweden I think one of them the top tax
rate is 58% and the other's 5 and the
other's and the other I think is 62% and
because I'm an American I just say like
that's all UK yeah all
that but a lot but a lot of
Scandinavians don't don't mind that cuz
I mean at least it includes all their
healthare all their education all the
way up to college level and so on
there's visible benefits to that then
you know yeah we pay like we pay like
40% and we have
potholes yeah and no books in our
schools what the [__] is that what's a
book yeah but Seth Rogan says it's
pretty good here oh that's right he's
stupid is the concept of libertarian
crazy in Europe is there like people
don't know what it means right
libertarianism is um if you if if you
say you're a Libertarian in England or
in Germany or France like they'll just
they'll just look at you like what do
you mean I heard because you're a crazy
right winger then right um maybe so
that's how they see it right I don't
they think our left wing is rightwing
true well okay so let me let me clarify
I was speaking to a journalist in
Austria right and she used to work for
the BBC's and we had a deep conversation
and she said that the American left is
still fiscally right and still
considered conservative and not that
crazy compared to Europeans so our
Bernie which is crazy left to us is
still kind of right and moderate to the
Europeans is that is that how you guys
that's true of some countries okay so
you're I mean Europe is dozens and
dozens of countries so they're they're
all yeah they're they're all
pretty yeah they're they're all quite
different in that regard but that would
certainly be true in some countries yeah
um but yeah I mean if you're what's your
favorite country you've been to I don't
have a favorite country damn no I don't
have I have favorite countries but least
favorite every everywhere's got
a he's in it I don't know no no no the
US in my top five countries man I love
the USA well cuz he could be with this
people here like he has the range right
so that's why he USA us what do his
people Joe right
Wingers if you're when you're planning
to have a kid if you are yeah where
would you want your kid to be born and
raised born wherever they get the most
passports wherever it makes most sense
for them raised um one of the golf count
trees wow really okay UAE so there's not
a lot of War there huh it's the safest
part of the entire world I heard Bahrain
is like lit Bahrain is lit Bahrain Qatar
UAE Saudi saudi's coming up man saudi's
going to crush it in really next couple
decades I also heard they have this wild
thing that I don't think California is
aware of called desalination plants
where you can like you can actually
there's like a whole ocean so like I
guess we're running out of water and
stuff but like there's this whole weird
ocean that you can like just take from
yeah and pull water from it and bahin
does that h
cuz we're screaming drought every
[__] year but we have the ocean right
there and it rains but they don't know
how to catch it yeah just go like this
and like this dude we have 10 million
people in La if they just went outside
did like that and put in the bucket
isn't it like illegal to collect rain
water in some places here maybe it in
the states I believe it we have weird
laws yeah I don't know about California
but I don't there's some rules around
collecting rain water so my American
brain when I think about the gulf
countries I go oh there's always War
it's dangerous no Wars at all there's
there's there's always some kind of
bombing or something going on no I mean
that's another part that's another part
of the Middle East I mean if you're yeah
I mean if you're Israel Palestine Syria
like that Iraq that Iran the UAE Dubai
no the gulf countries no but at least
we're trying to you know make those
places more peaceful though more peace
pretty
lit you feel me yeah and you know I I I
grew up in Saudi Arabia so I'm used to
man what was it like growing up in Saudi
Arabia really just perfect amazing um
not perfect man noh's perfect but um
it's also where it's saying like I I
grew up in an xat community so where I
grew up looked visually it looked like a
suburb in LA or
Houston yeah visually first time I ever
came to California remember when I went
to Orange County and I was like it looks
like Saudi what I felt the same thing
when I first went to Houston maybe it's
my ignorance cuz when I think Saudi
Arabia I think like it is a giant like
you well no I think I think zubie grew
up in Aladdin's [__] Palace or
something yeah everything everything
squiggling magic carpets 100%
camel yeah that's the national anthem
yeah of the UK for sure that's so funny
so you guys have regular ass houses like
we have regular houses but with flying
carpets yeah of course iMagic carpets
just in the
back I thought their houses would be way
bigger it was actually funny cuz um I
went to so I went to school in Saudi
from kindergarten to fifth grade and
then when I was 11 I went to boarding
school in the UK so from 11 to 20 I was
going to school in UK plus University
but I still lived in Saudi Arabia and
when I was like when I was 11 12 in
boarding school I used to get so many
questions from other students and you
know people were from all over the world
I was like what Saudi Arabia like you
and you could just tell them anything
and they believe
it you could you could just make you
could just make stuff you be like oh
like you know my camel riding my camel
to school through the desert and this
and they're just like I would believe
that right now I feel you go like this
you go like this I'm going pour the sand
out and you make a
wish yeah it was uh it was pretty fun
everyone has a genie you're like the
teacher turns his back we shake the
sunnd dial we got a little bit longer of
a lunch break like for all I know that's
accurate yeah but um but yeah it was a
cool place have any of you been anywhere
in the Middle East mm no okay I think
it's our propaganda to don't go there
cuz if we see it for ourselves we're
going to fall in love yeah how how is it
for women out there
awesome um again suck on that yeah suck
on that woman again suck on that woman
again let let me not be not like the
whole Middle East but um yeah like
places I can speak if you're talking
like a do do we're talking about like
where you grew up specifically oh where
I grew up fantastic no problem yeah no
problems at all um yeah but people have
different different people going to have
different experiences got all this
propagandas about women in in that area
right in the Middle East yeah well in in
and then specifically I say Saudi Arabia
and and Dubai right U Dubai I've heard
that's what I heard like if they saw her
like this would they go cover up lady
yeah or like if she if she's got like a
[__] you know but light she's wearing
much more than many women do in Dubai oh
yeah I'm in Dubai and I'm like y this is
this is this is Haram these women need
to cover you're in the US okay you have
to remember um you guys probably don't
know this I mean if you're talking Dubai
I mean only 10% of the population is
Emira 90 it's 90% experts really 90% 90%
wow I'm pretending to understand what
that means so 90% of the population is
from other countries got it yeah it's
Americans Brits Canadians Indians
pakistanis Australians and emirati means
type of illuminati people that it's a an
amirati is someone from the United Arab
Emirates I think it's a lounge at the
airport I don't know I'm kind of
thinking it's more what Steve said
they're employees of the airline yeah I
think it's the lounge at the
airport oh it's the girls with the Red
Hats yeah yeah the 10% of the country is
just that hey zubie littlest known fact
about yourself or maybe the most
misunderstood thing about you most
misunderstood thing about me gosh
there's a lot of conspiracy theories
about me last couple years what's the
best in juic the best one the best one
is that I'm not real and that I'm AI
what that's crazy wait I don't actually
touch him Steve touch him yeah I
can't he's a hologram this is just ADV
someone's really going to believe that
yeah yeah so that that's the that's the
funniest one I hope they
do we have a whole Guardian so if I
didn't ask to touch you they would get
on that's right they'll be like I can't
believe they didn't ask them about the
AI thing consent very important it's
very important to our audience do you
actually have a woke audience uh oh yeah
the most woke ever they're so woke the
woke show ever yeah this is the walk
show on YouTube really show on YouTube
we get actually accused for both sides
yeah yeah it's pretty fun yeah that's
good that's good yeah one day where uh
lip tards the next day were Trump
supporting rightwing mag magga guys yeah
and there's no way to say we're just
we're just Bob do Republicans [__]
who
[Laughter]
cares